few games have promised and then
delivered as much mayhem as borderlands
the loot em up from gearbox software
with the spin-off of the series on the
horizon with tiny tina's wonderlands we
decided it was time to take a look back
so here's the history of borderlands
[Music]
in 2007 gearbox software had some
interesting projects in the works they
were in pre-production on a game based
on the movie aliens i wonder what
happened to that one and we're
apparently in talks with director
michael mann to make a heat game
brother
you are going down
the team was also deep in production on
another title a hybrid first person
shooter and role-playing game called
borderlands the team were familiar with
making first person shooters after
working on expansions for half-life as
well as the pc port of halo combat
evolved but wanted to combine their
knowledge of making first-person shooter
games with their love of loot grinding
in titles like diablo to create a
shooter that would have loot coming out
of every orifice the game was revealed
via the september 2007 gameinformer
cover and even during this first look
the ambition was clear the game was
built for co-op in mind from the start
with players taking control of one of
the three playable characters roland
mordecai and lilith and playing solo
with ai or with up to three others
online or in split screen co-op there
were vehicles to drive around the
expansive wastes of the planet pandora
numerous skills to unlock and to scratch
that looting itch gearbox boasted over
000 unique weapons which would be
procedurally generated for players we've
created an ai system that actually
develops our weapons for us and as a
result there's millions of guns in the
game there's more weapons in borderlands
than in every shooter on the 360 and
every shooter on the playstation 3 added
together
while the game informal article offered
a few images of the game the first
trailer wouldn't arrive until almost a
year later at e3 2008 and compared to
the wacky colorful borderlands we know
today the borderlands of 2008 was
dare i say it a little generic looking
i'll tell you the same thing i told all
those who came before you
it doesn't exist
and it seemed that gearbox knew it too
testers kept comparing the game to id
software's rage and the recently
released fallout 3 and there was a
clashing of themes the gameplay was
ridiculous and over the top but the
visuals suggested gritty realism
the team was 75 of the way through the
project and didn't have the money to
reboot it so they switched up the art
style to look more like ink lined comic
books and scrapped the quote boring
abilities from the skill trees
emphasizing the wackier ones the new art
style was a hit but an awful lot of work
to implement so gearbox employees from
other games started helping out on
boardlands in their spare time
borderlands launched in october 2009
shoulder to shoulder with juggernauts
like uncharted 2 halo 3 odst and modern
warfare 2 but it was a surprise hit with
xbox 360 copies even selling out in many
stores on the east coast of the us
praise was heaped upon its gameplay
which was at its best when players
grouped up to play together with players
finding the loop of shooting enemies
gathering loot and leveling up intensely
satisfying there was always another
enemy to shoot another gun to get and
another skill to unlock each of the now
four vault hunters offered their own
unique powers and the game would sing
when played together with friends in
co-op death didn't necessarily mean the
end either if you were downed in battle
killing another enemy would give you a
second wind pushing you back into the
fight the new art style worked in its
favor making the expansive world of
pandora visually appealing and more in
line with the game's over-the-top nature
less positively received was the game's
story which was described as thin in our
review players would take control of one
of the vault hunters who would scour
pandora an almost barren planet that had
been picked over by one of the
universe's many corporations to find key
fragments that when combined would
unlock a vault full of untold riches
helping you out on your quest is
claptrap you may call me by my locally
designated name claptrap an excitable
robot who would unfortunately go on to
become the mascot for the series
seriously your arms tired i played the
duke of buckingham and reaches a third
with ian mckelly ass this is bushwick
borderlands received four pieces of
downloadable content and while they
offered the usual new missions areas
weapons and enemies they also acted as a
test bed for the developers to try out
new ideas borderlands sold 2 million
copies in just 2 months high numbers for
a new ip pushing its way to market
during the busiest time of year and
while a sequel was a no-brainer
according to gearbox it took them a few
years to actually announce it
in august 2011 publisher 2k and gearbox
officially revealed borderlands 2 and
while initial details were scant gearbox
promised that the sequel would be bigger
and better than the first game offering
new character classes weapons enemies
and areas to explore as well as an
ambitiously crafted story
at gamescom that year gearbox offered a
glimpse of what that meant the game's
weapon system had been replaced the ai
had been improved more voice acting had
been added and the quest and vehicle
systems had been overhauled
the story had been heavily criticized in
the first game so in order to create a
better connection between the gameplay
of borderlands and its story the lead
designer and the lead writer worked more
closely together for borderlands 2. the
goal was to make a story so ridiculous
that it would be beyond criticism
something to fit the nature of the
gameplay itself
one of the biggest changes came with the
cast of playable characters the four
original vault hunters were replaced
with axton meyer salvador and xero with
two more launching later as dlc but that
didn't mean the end of the original
vault hunters they returned as npcs and
quest givers in the game a nice nod for
those who got attached while playing
borderlands 1. the new and old heroes
were teaming up against handsome jack
the charming president of the nefarious
hyperion corporation who brings his
forces to pandora hoping to open another
vault on the planet i mean don't get me
wrong it's cute that y'all think you're
the heroes of this little adventure but
you're not gearbox promised a bigger
better sequel and boy did they deliver
fans loved exploring the more expansive
exciting world of pandora and all of the
new opportunities for mayhem it
presented reviewers praised the writing
in particular new characters like tiny
tina but more about her in a bit the
stalker thought was all in fun
ghost bandit but borderlands 2 wasn't
without its controversies the developers
caught flack for referring to the
macromancer skill tree as the girlfriend
mode for lesser skilled players with its
actual name becoming best friends
forever in the uk borderlands 2 was the
most pre-ordered 2k game ever and by
2014 it became the highest selling 2k
game in history selling well over 12
million copies by 2015. it came as no
surprise then that hollywood came
knocking with lionsgate announcing a
film of the series in 2016. while it
still hasn't been released as of early
2022 huge names like jamie lee curtis
kate blanchett and jack black are
attached to star borderlands 2 had a
number of pieces of downloadable content
including new vault hunters gage the
mechromancer and krieg the psycho 2013's
tiny tina's assault on dragon keep was a
vast departure from the story of the
vault hunters where tina ran a tabletop
game of bunkers and badasses the pandora
take on dungeons and dragons and the
vault hunters would gather as a party to
rescue butt stallion from the evil
handsome sorcerer the pack was well
received later being released as a
standalone one shot in 2021 and serving
as the inspiration for the spin-off game
tiny tina's wonderlands
after the release of the wildly
successful borderlands 2 gearbox began
working with 2k australia to make a
prequel that would bridge the story and
explain how handsome jack rose to power
in the first place the majority of
production was conducted by 2k australia
but certain key team members like the
writers of borderlands 2 worked with
them to craft the game in this new title
hyperion employee jack finds clues to a
vault on a moon of pandora and hires
four vault hunters to crack it open for
him the four playable characters had all
appeared in previous games in one way or
another either as bosses or npcs
including series mascot claptrap
pre-sequel offered a few tweaks to the
known borderlands formula like adding
new weapon types vehicles like the
hovercraft as well as low gravity areas
and the need to use o2 canisters for air
which would let you double jump when you
had them equipped pre-sequel didn't set
the world on fire with reviewers
criticizing the story and some
repetition in the late game it was
initially released for the ps3 xbox 360
and pc and was later brought to ps4 xbox
one and pc as part of the handsome
collection bundled with borderlands 2.
2k australia was sadly shattered in 2015
a few months after the game's launch
i want you to know the promotion that
you worked so hard to get
that's still coming to you that's why
i'm gonna make you assistant vice
janitor
in 2014 telltale games began to release
tales from the borderlands an episodic
adventure game set in the borderlands
universe
the project came about when gearbox and
telltale were sitting at neighboring
tables at the spike video game awards in
2012. the two companies got to chatting
and over a few drinks the idea to set a
telltale game in the borderlands
universe came up
while tales from the borderlands did
have some action in it it was a far cry
from the bombastic mayhem of the main
series well that didn't stop you did it
at least the money was real however fans
still praised the story it's two
protagonists rhys and fiona as well as
the choice driven gameplay when telltale
games closed in 2018 the five episodes
were pulled from sale until 2k managed
to obtain the rights and re-released the
series almost three years later
after the release of borderlands 1 and 2
gearbox was a little tired of the series
and so shifted its sights onto different
projects including battleborn a hero
shooter meets moba battleborn was not a
success partly because it received
middling reviews and partly because
blizzard released its own hero shooter
overwatch just a few weeks later
battleborn eventually closed down but it
turned out the experience working on
something new was just what the team at
gearbox needed as is the gearbox way the
team wanted to go bigger and better with
the third installment no longer just
centered on the planet pandora
borderlands 3 allowed players via their
ship sanctuary 3 to traverse the galaxy
to find vaults that were hidden on other
planets before the children of the vault
could after handsome jack's defeat in
borderlands 2 a new power had risen in
the form of a cult loosely inspired by
streamer culture with its two leaders
looking to grab the vaults for
themselves like with previous titles
borderlands 3 offered procedurally
generated loot and promised over 1
billion guns for players to potentially
find co-op also received some tweaks
thanks to the level sinking system
everyone could play together regardless
of their level and each would be matched
by level appropriate enemies and for
those who hate squabbling over loot you
could set your game so that each player
would receive level appropriate drops
borderlands 3 released in september 2019
and received two season passes worth of
content including game packs new skill
trees and a new game mode which was
basically a type of borderlands battle
royale thanks to an exclusivity deal
with the epic game store it was
exclusive to that storefront on pc for
six months leading to other games in the
series being review bombed on steam that
is a deal breaker but not for me
borderlands 3 was eagerly anticipated
and the game even had a crossover with
fortnite it reviewed really well with
reviewers praising the fact that it
expanded the borderlands gameplay
formula and offered payoffs for story
beats that fans had been following for a
decade as of the end of 2019 borderlands
3 has sold over 8 million copies and its
success helped the franchise hit over a
billion dollars which brings us to tiny
tina's wonderlands which once again sees
tina in the role of bunker master as she
guides you and your party through an
epic high fantasy adventure there's one
alone who can wield fate one alone whose
story is in their own hands
the fade maker
that's you
instead of choosing from a pre-made
vault hunter the game allows you to
create your own character and mix and
match your skills not only can you use
guns in the game but now you can use
melee weapons like swords as well as
magic to fend off the hordes of enemies
you'll be up against the majority of the
game is in first person but when
traversing the overworld your characters
turn into cute tabletop miniature
versions of themselves it also features
a pretty high profile cast including
andy sandberg and will annette i am
valentine gallant adventurer the scary
stabby one is fret which was your
favorite borderlands game let us know in
the comments and make sure to subscribe
to gamespot for more on tiny tina's
wonderlands coming your way very soon
thanks for watching
[Music]